I told you after the november eighth
election of donald trump that
progressives have been reinvigorated in
terms of understanding how corporate
media failed us and how independent
media is the path forward if
progressives really want to have
long-term success in the national and
and uh state-level elections going
forward we can't rely on corporate media
we started a fundraiser last week at
david pakman.com slash donate that
fundraiser has now crested the five
thousand dollar mark and now is really
the time to get things going this is the
last sort of core week of uh of 2016
next week of course i'm ending with
christmas at the end of the week and the
new years the week after this is the
last sort of full core basic work week
of 2016 and we really need your help to
continue pushing the campaign and
fundraiser for word up we have awesome
new perks that are only available
through the campaign to awesome t-shirts
which i'm going to be wearing as soon as
my sample t-shirts come in these are
t-shirts that I think you're really
going to like they are only available
through the fundraiser david pakman.com
slash donate the first is the
established in 2005 david pakman show
graphic t-shirt this is it has sort of
the logo and one of those established in
a stamp type graphics it is only
available through the campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate as a perk 2005
producer pat was six years old at that
time I read on the internet I don't know
if that's true Pat but I read uh no not
11 okay yeah so the interview can't
believe everything you read on the
internet also only available through the
david pakman show fundraiser at david
pakman.com slash donate is the only hey
treat male t-shirt that has ever existed
this is a sort of reinterpretation of
one of the hatred mail banners that we
use during hatred mail on the show this
is available as a t-shirt again only
through the david pakman fundraiser at
david pakman.com slash donate the most
popular perks so far bumper sticker
followed by the 2017 calendar followed
by the regular t-shirt and then the
hoodie my prediction is these new shirts
are going to really make a play for top
perks I think those new shirts are
awesome it's gonna be huge it's gonna be
tremendous yeah be big-league everywhere
telling me all about it no doubt about
it but I really need your help if there
are some major donors sort of waiting in
the wings please wait no longer this
includes those who have reached out to
me saying David I'm thinking about
making a big contribution this includes
those who I know are out there that have
not reached out to me please get those
donations in at david pakman.com slash
donate i will update you on the status
of the campaign tomorrow for now we will
take a quick break